et un pour faire plaisir
pire ce qui suit à la feuille
la pop est mort
olé
ça parce que ça faisait gagner une
minute mais vous ne referme ce programme
quand elle passe les carmencita elle
déplace 100000 gars plus il s'enflamme
plus ce problème
elle criait
ronnie dargaud elle est chère aux
communes il n go et aux années de chaque
semaine est de l île avait eu des
couleurs madrilènes
tu connais pas mme mireille mireia miro
mireille qu'est merveille
le mans
lorsque mon coeur sommeil j'ai le train
de marcher je me réveille
mir est dans les temps à compter du à
plein temps sont le ginza
michy comme un réel atout p'tit pas
attraper en sang
chez des mimosas rosette et pinard je
suis complètement perdue parce que je
savais pas que j'ai chanté cette chanson
c'est par gad je me souviens pas de mon
texte mais que marcia toutes les voies
au lieu de vous marrer
du lot tu connais pas venir dieu
mireille dira yacht dirai quelle
merveille
lorsque
vingt deux cas je me réveille irait
ras si tu avais irrita sur tarn
elle et son époux et envoûtant
tu verrais d'un seul coup les mille et
une nuits de la percée de la barbie cet
immense et noir elle a illuminé
alors sous le voile on imagine ans ed
devant le et mystérieux dans le fond je
suis presque sûr qu'elle ait eu
tu connais pas mireille
vraiment merdé
même que je suis tellement ému que qu'un
juge à 200 en jeu ma trempe dans les
parents quand j'évoquais sommeil chez le
train de marseille et quand je me
réveille
pyrénées en mai
la compagnie